[Music]
i wouldn't say we made it
but we
[Music]
we
all natty all natty
creatine duck eggs
bcaas all vegan diet
besides the duck eggs
[Music]
quick gym sash as always early morning
started with cardio i got my swollen
with the boys
at zoo as usual and then uh
what i gotta get below the belt in santa
monica first
and then find the kid with talon
chappelle
eric griffin and myself that's it man
that's
the day let's get it keep on rising keep
on shining you remind them what we call
a perfect timing but you better keep on
grinding
[Music]
that's a picture of my dad working out
with us at zoo culture
uh monday through saturday meeting the
squad chapelle and mark work out of zoo
culture to get swole
my dad came up there show us a few
things showed us a few freaking things
papa's in shape
a lot going on go to think boy right now
subscribe but almost 17 000 now it's
been about
up for a week so we moving baby you get
100 thousand we'll pick those three
random fans man
let's get it
hey to everybody who wish me a happy
father's day i'm sorry i didn't respond
i agree it's very tough for me guys
because i don't care i i appreciate it
it's just that
i don't want to have to go youtube
i have some lengthy people wanna people
want you to celebrate
at the same level that you celebrate
with your close family members with them
yeah yeah they wanted you to do it at
the same level every time it's similar
to when like
let's say you like you book a show or
something right the agent calls you go
hey man
you booked it and you're like this yes
and you tell your family you're like oh
guess what we did it right then the next
person you see
they go hey man congratulations on that
show and you might go like this oh
thanks
yeah then they get it then they go oh
can you that's all you got
the energy's not the same celebrating
with you on the same level
like i can't celebrate what everybody's
just saying right there's levels you
know what i mean
i don't need to be that way with you
it's like that's like i said i'm engaged
okay
right oh really yes yeah we knew that so
everybody says to me
you guys are like this guy's like oh
really i was like
oh my god yeah dude everybody goes oh
dude you're wow you're gay
[Laughter]
so it's like you know i don't have to
say that kind of stuff like you know
get off my yeezys dawg that's it that's
a wrap
i saw the kicks you saw my workout
i saw below the belt found the kid with
their griffin that's it
that's it for the day still haven't
eaten not a freaking ounce of food
so you want to be a podcaster huh
i'm out